want me to build anonymous I'd like to
thank our lead Iowa and I'd have to say
to that I had a very negative opinion of
of Ali Dharma and I watched the YouTube
video when you know he was getting
married and some of the stuff that he
went through and I couldn't believe it
I've actually quite touched by something
and he became human in front of my eyes
[Music]
here would be broke
I've been here for a couple of weeks
with other in really well automatically
happen in which women address were both
on a desk on people who have a common
understanding internationally and moving
a lot of talk about today obviously the
first one it and that important in news
to people slap yes completely some I'm
so we're going to talk about three
things that you mentioned about the
bottleneck when he insulted a pavement
has gone up whatever whatever of your
foot and also the muscle cell and along
those lines which I don't know the heavy
panic for passengers I'll just go with
what he said now before we saw obviously
you mentioned let's go back to watching
Acharya
okay and you know they should happen
restaura and you said that they could be
because of your unfitted and the things
that they will see in this country if it
is interesting about okay what do you
keep taking out what are we little
context I know you can certainly if
you're going to start you're going to
use trigger words like ancestor to me to
see if I have a particular millisecond
but I have a particular belief system
that's not what you were speaking about
initially
immediately very clear last week once
again there was another incident with
sera in the party and during that
incident
a particular person said that he's going
to rip off his face and he's going to do
X Y Z - very violent the other people
with him to give credit from Muslims did
jumping and it was then I was here with
three or four people and I made clear
that it was made clear that it seemed as
if so I was about to be attacked this I
say has been growing for a period of
time there is I believe a lack of
respect in the park towards dark-skinned
black men and a lot of that disrespect
comes primarily from people of a Muslim
background Arab stroke Pakistani
background whereby they have a lack of
respect for black men because this means
all the Muslims in the park of course it
doesn't but what it does mean is that
from my opinion is that there is a
sizable minority that agrees with this
particular action mind you was very
clear because I've seen what build up
was built up over a period of time I
made clear that the law states that you
are allowed to use reasonable force in
defense of yourself and others I made
clear that if Sarah was attacked I don't
care what the odds are we're going to
battle it out because seemingly there
are people in the park that believe that
they have a right to tell grown adults
grown adult grown men what they should
say how they should say it when they
should say it and if they don't say in
the way that it's acceptable to them
then there is a chance that there that
there will be violence I don't agree
with that I don't agree of that I don't
agree with anybody who takes that
position my position is very clear I
will defend Muslims Christians atheist
black or white in this part if they have
an opinion and they for me as grown
adults they are allowed to voice their
opinion in this country there was a very
small patch of land that's about two
possibly three acres within High Park
where on a Sunday for the past 150
people have been able to come down and
say whatever they like you also though
you also though even though they can say
what they like you also have the choice
not to listen to what they have to say
you can walk them out you don't have to
hear what's being said there is a small
minority of Muslims that believe that
they do not want to accept this that
they are not going to follow the law of
the land and if you if you make the
mistake of critiquing Islam then there
is going to be a problem I don't accept
that
ok you know once you make it one thing
to be missed out there is I'm seen that
because it contacted the two session
doesn't ask about what's on the topic
you know you said you were backup and
sorrow because you know you can't
[ __ ] do that problem no no no $0.20
no it's not in contact sorry
you can rewrite as well you want to make
your point then I will tell you how it
was made and how that report was made
you just made that the reason I'm saying
that is not lightweight I'm not using
against you on to my push-ups I'm going
to you'll understand but ok so from your
side what you meant by not raising what
I said what I said was that I am very
clear that Sarah is my is my brother yes
there are is also my black brother and I
was very clear I also pointed out when I
said that because some people became
triggered oh why do you have to mention
color well because we have a joint we
have a joint a shared history a shared
history of discrimination a shared
history of disrespect
yeah that comes towards dark-skinned
people but prior to me saying that what
I said - Ali what I said Ali was that
look this is my views I said if it's
Christian if it's Muslim if it's atheist
if it's one if it's black I will support
them then the fan if they wish to have
free speech yeah in the part and even if
it was on them
I would also become them because even
though it would look as if I'm defending
that individual what I'm defend
and is the concept of free speech in a
world where there is very little free
speech just recently I cling back from
traveling to five or six countries in
Southeast Asia and once I enjoyed myself
in Southeast Asia the one thing that I
was very clear about was was the
astonishing like a free speech that was
in the booth in Southeast Asia so once
they had the appearance of a fully
functioning societies who people who
couldn't say what they wish to say I
don't wish that happening in London I
don't wish that happen in the UK with
something fairly precious here in Hyde
Park and if you have free speech you
should have a right yeah you should have
a right to exercise that free speech and
look last week when I was speaking I
came up to me it allows an idiot and and
I had a laugh with him when he called me
an idiot you know the reason why he has
a right to call me an idiot
he has a right it's a tripod this is not
out on the street he has a right to
community ax well I don't agree with you
I think they're talking hard he has a
right to say that but this one I also
have a right to answer him when the
laughter has died down
so let's now stick to the point and
let's see whether or not I am talking
car or whether I am an idiot you
understand but my argument is as I said
I'm very clear I am NOT for so-called
black supremacy so called white
supremacy Asian Superman has an Islamic
presumably Arab supremacy which seems to
be it seems to be on the rise then says
my argument is a fairly simple one
either we have free speech or we don't
if we have free speech who are you to
put conditions on anybody who wishes to
exercise that free speech it was in that
context that I said that whatever
happens where sorrow are concerns it
could have been Aladar the understand it
could have been go our digital it could
have be my homeboys from from from
content or ramping you have a right to
say what you say and it becomes very
very dangerous and it's a slippery slope
it's a slippery slope yet to a religious
dictatorship when people say you can to
take us and beat you critique us it's
got to be done in a way in which we find
acceptable
report yeah one one one thing because I
just really want emphasize on it is you
know the reason why I'm doing it I'm
going to get to my question and it would
if you will only understand what we had
completely noted with sorrow because of
what happened with your ancestors
because you understood our own eliminate
that way you know like your your father
who claim you are in that generation and
they went through an illness okay you
said that be the road you saying for
example even though I specify that he
did say be a Muslim Jew Christian
whatever he did say about the fact that
he said move Sarah is because obviously
what the black people went through in
this country when they're his father his
father cream
he said that played a bit of a role in
what you said there's for me everyone
okay good so didn't remember okay yeah I
just wanted to clarify that
now firstly what I want to say is any
kind of racism that wouldn't say be the
n-word be the monkey on this that to me
is really clear Islam doesn't teach
Islam the hadith the literature you find
me and anyone that comes and utter the
words to me show something very clear
Islam one percent of your son hasn't
even gone into your head one percent of
Islam as I'm going to treat because it's
one person one into your head you know
racism is not allowed anyways besides
that you idiot you have black Muslims
you're insulting him like where is the
common sense and beside that racism that
exists in Muslim community but looking
at some I want to make that very clear
I'll be honest with I'm a river system I
stopped at racism and I wanted to marry
a certain specific girl not reject is
why because you're not my culture that's
beside the point what are talking about
my marriage it yes okay now what big bro
mentioned was for example their right to
criticize look we gives our we come here
every week or every day every Sunday and
we're around different parts of London
around the UK around the world why do we
go out because they'll criticize our
religion you can criticize you come to
me and say why did the [ __ ] my
reaction let's talk about why this
unless it is let's talk about it now
people said you believe this violence
and it's not let's talk about it we have
no problem with teaching our religion
however when you
common in Seoul as in as a Muslim the
Prophet Muhammad peace upon him is my
role model
yes I the perfect said I did not come to
prepare I did not come for nothing but
of the fed good character good manners
and this is one thing that as Muslims we
luck I'm going to be sure I'm going to
be around the boat what's been happening
what's been happening for the past
couple of weeks
I'm sorry be a Muslim enormous penis
just was moving the oxygen is disgusting
and it is the Allah His Prophet and his
companions are free from this action
because the public doesn't teach you to
a so many constants we're in so we
racist ridiculous
so if Sam is free from these actions I
want to make that very clear now going
back to criticism you said for example
Abu Bakr get you a pagan go and suck the
clitoris of our lungs I'm not a lot your
God that you worship and even you
measure that the Prophet said something
similar along the line which I haven't
heard but let's go with about let's go
with it and say this instead now this is
the reason why I was asking a question
about sorry
now what you and your father and your
forefather went through they went
through all this food right
they went through this madness do you
think I would sound a bit appreciate the
future a future in this picture here is
the condition is begins last year
survivor do you think I was sound a bit
like that if I was to say you know what
you came to me and said you know what
look here our forefathers went from this
they got killed they got kicked out of
their house they wouldn't go tricks that
her up and then I came in said yeah yeah
all good all good but did you see what
they said the people who did that to
them you take your father came and said
hey ghost of the clitoris of your you're
white but you're going to come to say to
me nd I'm telling you they went through
this this this this this and all you can
concentrate is this man the least we
could have done is say that or swear or
at least be something so what we're
seeing a lot of Hamid tteonan is that
the pagan Arabs do you know what we put
the Muslims roof you have no idea
they killed the Companions woman women
they put a you know that what was it
goes out
woman sighs applause yes they kicked
them out from the land they took over
the house it's a positive and the least
they can do is they go to your God and
sucky clitoris once eNOS
these are human being the companions the
prophets are seldom get is a messenger
using human beings the hadith we need to
look into I don't know but what I'm
seeing is what I'm seeing is there me
please leave you can expect from them
and turned a blind eye is to say you
know what he said that understandable
after what the reasons understandable
yes this is my reply to you that the
claim that you make would you understand
where I'm coming from with what I said
and you can in mind what your
forefathers went to because it's very
similar okay let me just say to you that
an sometimes when we make a statement
it's right that we should give contacts
to the statement that we made the
statement that our leader wadis made was
in response for something that I said
earlier and so what I'm going to do is
point out what I said earlier and then
you decide whether or not the response
from Ali da WA was the right response
the question that I art was in regard to
sorrow and the question that was asked
was do you believe that sir our language
was acceptable the answer is no they
don't believe it was respectable the
understand you believe it was acceptable
no they don't believe that it was
acceptable why don't you believe it was
acceptable I lead our warfare and if I'm
if I'm wrong anywhere please stop me
nevermind I leave I was said we love the
prophet alayhi Salaam more than we love
our own mother and if you insult the
Prophet there are some Muslims firstly
the younger ones will want to do X Y Zed
to you and I support that
yeah this is what a leader was said did
I didn't ask for that
what sorry folks I'll take the proper I
get at an individual yes Sarah has
insulted the Prophet in front of you
yeah I walked away I said you know what
we must have my discussion Zahra
you slide insulting I'm not gonna drop
too
goodbye and I will talk however I said
it's somebody it's not just about the
[ __ ] if somebody thought your mother or
come to told you an N word to your face
it's not unacceptable would I understand
a black man we've been called and n-word
and he goes - I have empathy and I
understand him however would I look at
that black man when he walks away or you
know I respect you you're the bigger man
however if he was upset angry and
physically wanted to do something I
would say you know what I don't need it
okay even though I disagree I don't need
all right did you say to you I'm going
to get back on to what I say was the
original point as regards Sauron one of
the reasons why I asked the question one
of the reasons why I asked the question
is that do you believe sir our word was
his language wasn't what respectable for
the Prophet of Islam alayhi Salaam the
person it wasn't respectful okay do you
believe that any condemnation of your
prophet of your prophet using foul
language is accessible no it's not what
I dented was when I spoke about religion
were saying what is it about religion
and the addict that they had the
adherence e of those in that religion
that they believe it because they can't
know as a fire it's very it's their
faith that separates them from everybody
else so you say that I'm a Muslim
Laila Allah Muhammad Rasul Allah this is
what it is now - yeah yeah yeah I know
can I just say - what that's funny you
already know you already knew that was
my background we understand
so my coin was a simple one do you
accept yet do you accept that sorrows
language was outrageous and should it be
condemned to people who have faith
beyond says yes okay what I then said
was what I'm going to do now all I'm
going to do is mention yet nothing of my
own opinion what I'm going to mention
now is both the Quran and the Sunnah
yeah nothing else since that language is
so terrible that it would trigger some
Muslims to threaten to kill somebody in
high bar you understand
ask you then let's look at the hobby for
example when when when Muhammad he said
pagan you understand he could only say
pagan now with the passage of time but
at the time at the time of muhammad
alayhi salam when he started he was the
one that was a pagan because he was the
one that was coming with a new religion
which was fundamentally different from
the 360 religions that surrounded the
cover the understand so let's just be
very clear about them there were people
there were people there were people
there were people at that particular
time that had their particular face and
their particular beliefs doesn't matter
whether you believe it was right
they had that faith that they believed
that it was right when I found I'm not
sure if you've got a problem to manage
there might be earth earth earth earth
well who came to the Prophet and when he
spoke to the prophet and he was trying
to ask the Prophet not to go to war with
the tribe they understand the message
was sent out from the prophet alayhi
Salaam and he told him yes and he taught
and these messages were rounded so bogum
he said go and bite the penis of your
father and then he said don't use any
euphemisms well you can shake your head
you understand I can tell you that what
I'm saying is correct just a link just
enormous we can generally I say just a
little while after this because we
remember we're talking about whether
language is offensive or not and if we
accept if we accept that for our use
language which is not acceptable if we
accept that through our used languages
which is not acceptable and that would
trigger youth well let's look at all
language which we would find
unacceptable there was another hadith
there was another hadith and I you know
going to Google and check it yourself
there was another hadith I've actually
got the book in the Mojave area just
goes down there's got to hold it a
second
yeah now think about this just for a
moment
Abu Bakr yeah who it's supposed to be
one that one of the first rightly guided
bunnies
in the company of muhammad aleyhi salam
spoke to a man who had a belief how to
believe in his god it might not have
been your god similarly today when
muslims speak about the god of others or
people speak about the god of allah well
we don't believe in your God at that
particular time the belief in a lot
might well not have deemed the belief of
Abu Bakr and muhammad aleyhi salam but
what was the language what was the
language that was used by the first
rightly guided poly what was the
language that was used so his God which
was a nut we understand the language
that was used was grow and suck on the
clitoris of your God because you see
when we speak about language which is
acceptable and not acceptable if we're
going to condemn offensive language
let's not be let's not be particular in
room we condemn let's just say that we
confirm particular language now on this
particular point which I accept was that
well well Abu Bakr yeah it's just a man
and so he is fallible I'm sorry where
the Prophet of Islam alayhi Salam is
concerned is that he is not like all of
us yeah he is not like all of us this is
a man according to Islam who was being
separated from us yes let me guide it by
a last words Allah
thank you if you believe the narrative
by the angel jibreel
given yes given given chapter and verse
over 23 years I understand let and built
built the germinal which is Islam into
the B term of which it is today for 1.6
billion Muslims if the argument is that
you can have Islam but Islam must not be
critiqued because there are people who
can't control their feelings and they
say we will kill you if you if you state
an opinion which we're against my
argument my argument to you is this what
then is the difference what there is
apart from scale
what is the difference between the port
of people who would have that and the
people through what slaughter people
around the world because they say
something against Islam that they
dislike because I'd like to hear it okay
and firstly the hadith that he mentioned
about the patellar tendon pain go and
bite where your father's penis yeah
which I found nothing to do with
anyone's religion
this was actually set because a man was
boasting about his lineage yet so this
has a form of racism like hey my lineage
I come from this yeah so the public said
peace be upon him which he well deserve
because it's actually is actually
against what we've always seen because
over here woman boasted a my lineage on
from this time and the coffee saying go
and bite your father innocent you know
you're so big of the air like you
completely capable through it yes so the
problem is rebuking him in such a harsh
way to show how harsh Islam is against
this kind of ideology of security I'm
better than this guy Andrew Loura so the
perfect forum back in its place
not because of his religion because of
racism racism is the shape of
shaitaan/satan it's the trait estate
only the first thing I am better than
Adam this is in Islam so any moves in
the condom cause a black man or a white
man's this one of that word you are
carrying a trait of Satan with you which
is family totally against one saying to
our big bro and by the way I want to
spank him for being respectful every
time we mention mentioned the phosphorus
on his name it says alehissalaam yes
which I thank him because it shows that
he is a man that you know I'm sorry
not like sorrow I'm sorriest however
what I said before is this yes whoever
said is this yes with rock Hamdani you
know if I had shown that he was behind
it I merely shot idea what we're saying
is this yet we need to focus in the
context here because what big bro is
saying is mentioned what Ibaka said and
the Prophet said and this clean look
this is where these guys are getting it
from that's not right that's not correct
gonna be fair because naka said look at
the context guys they went look you guys
have to put yourself in their shoes your
mum's sorted kicked out your house
your clothes are taking yet Gucci
clothes are money whatever it may be yet
taken you
you have been kicked out from your house
you're not getting some next month and
they come to you and then you say to
them go and suck the citrus of your good
and then big broken this is how we sing
that to my man you're going to see blood
black bro big bro they found this and
this is that be rather I don't care what
they did all I care about is what you
said I'll say that's unfair and I not be
broke either I believe is the same
division see individual we have to put
things into context like I said before
what your forefathers went through it
will be so petty and discussing of me to
come and pick on a little thing that
your forefathers said to those who
oppress them this is not fair we have to
be fair and like I said before what you
mentioned about the penis thing the
Prophet it was nothing to do with the
man's religion he was boasting of
recently was a racist man and the
Prophet said that him seeing that it's I
think it's pity to come up it and say
here you know he's the best he's a
Messenger of Allah the best of mankind a
role model how was he saying the Aussie
doesn't fit he says in a city and that
man deserved it because this is the
reason why these individuals who come
and call you a monkey or call these
individuals or whatever the n-word I
should be honest what I come and say the
same thing yes I would go to them and
say you know well you're so proud of
your Pakistani lineage go and do this oh
I might say you know what I'll just
ignorance however the process saying
that doesn't in no way shape or form
mean okay yeah look this I think it's
catchy I think is really pretty to pick
on this because this racism and racism
is a problem that we are today till they
say like you said it's out there now
another point that I want to mention but
we were just went to America very
quickly and profitable and UFOs are
generated you know a little bit of a
little bit of bait and switch here and
I'll tell you the reason why when you
listen to this videos I want you to
rewind a big deal about 10 minutes and
heard what that Ali Dawa said what Ali
Baba said the reason why initially that
the Prophet label on one of the reasons
why he said the word but he said was
because these people I chased them from
their homes he regaled you with stories
of how a man
to spear and insert it into a woman and
the river chase from Nene's new
government running yeah that they were
chased that they were chased from their
land and this is the reason why I'm a
delayed alarm said what he said now it's
being changed because he's now got the
correct ID and that wasn't the reason
why he said it
he's and why he said it was because he
disagreed he disagreed you're right that
it wasn't religious it was more than
that he disagreed with what the man said
because what the man was doing quite
rightly was pointing out to Mohammed his
lineage in that particular part of the
world for me it was a disrespectful
statement yeah by muhammad aleyhi salam
let me just say this very quickly and
this is this is this is me one of the
cousins that exist in Islam at the
moment for me personally you can have
what you believe is a rightly structured
criticism of Islam and whatever said
what is the reason why he did that
yet instead of use using logic and
saying to yourself well on the surface
it doesn't actually make much sense
Ali then inserted the racist angle in it
I've read the hadith I have the Hobby on
my phone and in my book there was
nowhere where there were just one moment
please here yeah you cannot seem to show
you you have another Google here yes
there is no where there is no where and
I challenge you now a challenge ala Dawa
to show me one statement in that
particular hadith that alluded to racism
from this particular quote unquote
important quote forceful racist man
there is not one statement I'm going to
go out on a limb and I'm going to tell
you I haven't read that did it get
nothing we're going to go out on a limb
I'm going to go out on a limb but guess
what I didn't work you go out on and
then where I'm going to make the
statement and if I'm wrong I'm going to
be sure you'd be wrong I'm going to be
shown to be wrong but guess what
you know the great thing
and I said you know the great thing if
I'm wrong I'll apologize and see what I
have read I have read that planet that I
have rarely and I'm sorry I just think
I'm going to come to that injection and
carrier and let me just say to you let
me just say to you that for me was not
the reason there was no racism that was
mentioned in that statement lastly there
Ali Ali Ali said to me that one of the
things that he likes is that is that
obviously I respect the Prophet and I
will use I will use the right term when
I discussed the prophet alayhi Salaam
there are multiple reasons for them a a
because most people down here know that
aids my religion
my religion was Aslam my brother's true
of my brothers still remained Muslim
lives and probably a third of my family
still remain Muslim you understand but
let me just say this that does not stop
me from being able to critique Islam if
I wish to create Islam last point I
would make is this very very important
to be this point because and I just lost
my fault for a second but he mentioned
he mentioned surah and you know it's so
much better than throughout you just
explain something to you
surah I want to be very clear about this
surah remains my brother
yes my brother I want to be clear about
I look in the camera
surah remains my brother good or bad let
me tell you the difference now between
myself and some of what I say are the
triggered Muslims in Mossad I can say
that surah remains my brother and I love
surround my brother and I will defend
him as my brother if the questioner is
the question though is okay big bro the
language that you when there was a
discussion regarding muhammad alayhi
salam or Islam would you use the same
language as surah i state categorically
I would not and the reason why I would
not is because it doesn't work
for me because if I am going to be
having that discussion it's because I
want something back from that discussion
and I want it back in the best way
possible
however Syrah remains an adult and as an
adult he is not my child big man he can
do whatever he wishes to do because he
is a grown man with his own opinions
then assemble his own objectives would
be his own version of his life he can
say whatever he wishes to say so I just
want to make that very very clear in
fact look what I don't want if I divide
and rule tactic coming in to split me
between my brothers because I've seen
this before at the part where by you
will have a group of Muslims who were
around a black or around a particular
black brother and then all of a sudden
because inhibitors I'm not talking about
you here they have assured us that there
are some Muslims I didn't say all I did
then I could be condemned
yeah now there are a group of Muslims
there group of Muslims in the park and I
see what happens every time they deal
with a dark-skinned black man they'll
come up and they'll put up I'm a being
rude I put over my face you know what
you shouldn't be like him you know this
is the divide and rule tactic black
people have gone through this in the
West over the last 500 years we
recognize when it happens when it
happens the last one I'll make is this
there is a quite is a great deal of this
ingenuity amongst some people in this
park
do you honestly believe our arsonist as
a question do you believe that is myself
there's like four or five people that
I'm here with today
yeah we'll stand around do you honestly
believe that if something can start and
we believe we believe just as individual
Jesus
that's kind of kind of dark eternity do
you believe that we wouldn't go up to
our brother who we love who we love
outside of here
and have a conversation with our brother
you don't believe that one but we don't
care what you say yeah we care what I
say yeah yeah yeah yeah that's right
that's right Kelly no no no no
dimension it because you see it's very
important I don't believe what you
believe
so you have no right to impose your
belief or me I'm making I'm attorney
general Baker named the general general
of the general standards a general
statement the understand and this is
what happened this is what happens when
a black man makes a statement we all
know that in the black community one of
the real problems that we have in the
black community is the actual lack of
disrespect from other people who are
black who are quick to enjoying loss to
an ally who are quick to enjoin on to
the ideologies of others they understand
I could be rude am i rude sometimes
yes I am and you know what they are I
call them as a group of house [ __ ]
and now that's me being real did I do
that
okay that's because I'm a human being
and I'm fallible what I believe yeah big
but then you go ahead how can I go any
meeting again so you're apologizing that
you mention it well being taken off
target as well how do you talk about
this sort of thing yeah forget that
before that was you talking about my car
remember okay yeah
if I'm proven wrong okay by the way to
generate our great me I did proven wrong
by the way you said I did a switching
basis yes okay there's me one thing
about when to mention mmm true but maybe
I'm just an eclair fight so you
understand able to convey it firstly
guys what we need to understand it yet
we shouldn't have this mentality of ego
like it's me against big growth here
he's quickly and criticizing Islam and
I'm answering I don't want this to be
like hey me I might have any time your
videos not I lead our big big bro yes
this is a discussion that happen in
solution we're not here to win the
battle I'm not gonna be like yes one to
me this is childish yes I'm not here for
this now I want to clarify something I
mentioned when abu bakr said to that
pagan guy about going suck whatever
clitoris of that yes I set you very
clearly at the beginning when you said
for ten minutes behind if you guys go
back you will see that I said the
this is mentioned about the profit I
don't know I need to look into it
producer so I did not come and say that
the Prophet said this or said that
because they killed and no one ever said
that I said that for the other bucket
the veneration of a bucket that's the
reason I mentioned that but for the
Prophet I said I don't know what that is
about I need to look into it I have and
this is it and maybe big bro
can tell me if there's another one
because it's the only one that I know it
was narrated from obey may Allah be
pleased with him that's a man boasted of
his tribal lineage and told him by our
lineage and obey told him okay so this
reason the truck say hold on a second
and obey told him to bite his father's
mails member follows male member and
they said you were you were never given
two obscene speech he said we were
instructed to do that okay for her
obey by the messenger for so the be
hidden by the first witness the Prophet
Muhammad each opponent told into what
did I teach you that before this is a
man coming up boasting about his lineage
yes
so it would be petty it will be very
petty to come and say you know what
something that we all suffer from are
they rated them you'll get raised to the
more than me maybe yes so to come
because what you're doing when you
defend this you're defending those
individuals you might be KKK whatever it
may be whoever they hate it's that same
you know what you have a right to call
me monkey that's just your freedom of
speech where does freedom of speech stop
guys I can I come and say to you lady
nor a monkey your this no because look
freedom speech can I in this country yes
I can would I know I won't the story
life is through the need to discuss is
where does freedom of speech stop
because even in this country France
freedom of speech freedom speech zone
install the flag freedom of speech
freedom of speech we must be nothing
against the Queen you can't say this so
even in this country in the West freedom
sneezes hypocrisy you can read a mystery
speedo anything but you can see nothing
about gage you can't see nothing about
the truth you can't see a novella by the
Holocaust or except - except Jean so
what I'm trying to say is he are
defending what the Prophet said about
the man being racist the man deserve
this he deserves that you coming up and
this is the attitude that we shouldn't
have now bid for one thing that I
noticed yeah and I want to mention you
have this leap in a connection with your
black people yeah whatever it may be
we have the same in the Sun but we don't
we don't look at color we don't look at
black white yellow Chinese green in
Islam in Islam it teaches us how you are
so close from your black brothers or
whatever you have that thing because of
what's happened before I respect that
yes you guys went through madness
hundred percent however what you have
big bro with your way of thinking
whatever it may be I swear by Allah we
have the same with our black Baba and
white Baba Chinese whatever he is more
than even that we're going to be honest
yes our Muslim brothers and sisters
wherever they may be
so we I just want to make that clear
that in Islam it's not hey you're black
or hey your wife it's about your mother
in a stance and humanity this doesn't
mean I can practice this one cool okay
good now do Muslims do this and I'm
going to see I'm not going to come and
say we can't communicate every single
Morgan racist no concern there is
Muslims that are racist but they are
sadly either moving by name and or
nothing about Islam or they are Muslims
that nobody some but our Commission
isn't this wrong we need to ask the
question is this a transition if not
when I crash my car
I'm not going to call it stop blaming
the car your idiot this whole see what
you made me do no the cars were to blame
and to blame so we can't blame Islam is
there moving to our races yet have I
someone racism hell yes trust me I
suffered waited in his world and a lot
of black people who consciousness they
stuff for racism - so I've clarified of
abortion rates long I've clarified on
the buckle issue of clarified the
narration that he told him told me about
that I did never mention from the
beginning that it's about that no coming
to sorrow did I just say to you but on
this particular ID but when I go out on
a limb it be patron your hand where he
was discussed and racism in there yeah
and that's the reason why my bosses of
his tribal images yeah but somebody's at
me that means how come they see look you
know my lineage yes sir better than
yours I'm better than you I mean you're
not racist that's more important is that
really okay what do you define as making
the corporate you're very soon
everything very very clear but I've made
my point before I've been after such a
reformatory cuz you know what Patel you
see another observer
touch up on that yet to me that's racism
stay out racism see I'm trying to see so
commentate just okay so come and see
okay come on come on say hey my lineage
you know where where the runners you are
the best
but was it a good reason I'm better than
Adams oh you're gonna say limit come on
guys this review will be in petia with
hey look you did it come on come on
let's be fair you listen what are the
same limit and don't order of the same
race because you see the only reason why
I went round in miniature yeah I
understand that but you mentioned race
one things here that today yesterday you
have as a black man a choice if you want
to become Muslim if you look born into
that particular thing however if you are
born as a black man and they have no
choice as to whether you're black or not
the same way if you want to live image
he's going to commentate the same thing
this my little pony - it's not because
of your acquaintance is linear with this
race this is what you're doing I'm
saying to you that race is a separate
entity in and of itself and you still
have no choice and you still have not
you still have not pleasing to me how
that is wrinkled very carefully it's not
in my face if I thank you oh do you know
my name is yeah I've got like I don't
like my four brothers and I've got yes
and I've got my that's my name
you know what you thought extrapolate or
me go one environment into rings and
father it's Laura what's the difference
of me come and say I'm white I'm better
than you no black or I'm communicating -
you know what my limit users manual
Raymond attorney and upon the Socrates
anything good education great race is
definitively up here there is no
question that when you're speaking about
a black man and if a black man's in your
presence he knows that he is a black man
when you speak about lineage in the
context that you're speaking about they
can never be about race and you cannot
say that religion had nothing whatsoever
to do available because Muhammad's
action Mohammed's actions in rebuking
him he was rebuked he was rebuked and if
you read further down he was revealer by
who
before the messenger of allah Neela's
will be he was rebuked came in yes i'm
in this particular hadith here yeah in
fact when you speaking about
he was he was put in his place because
of the foul language that was used yeah
that was agreed with here by the prophet
because what you did you spoke about you
base but you didn't speak about where
they said previously which is which is
what Muhammad is said and then he said
when I would eat a man he did say before
that you are just going to be made clear
to everybody else that prior to that
that what what what prophet of allah la
alarma said is that when you say this
yeah say it without you permissive which
means say it in a way the understand
that is as disrespectful as you can get
I don't know my skin can be nothing here
which might address to say to you know
where I come from we call that religious
so country and that's claim romantic not
well that's your perception that and
you're allowed your perception but your
perception is what mine is love is love
attention
well which one is worse I am white I'm
better than your black here my lineage
is better than yours and which one is
worse a must the magistrate is that I
don't get engaged in that level of
debate where race is concerned I'm going
to say the reason why because when I
speak about race when I speak about race
I speak about race from the context that
I know not everything but a great deal
about my black history I would never and
just saying to you I would never go for
the descendant of who they say are Jews
who died in the [ __ ] world war that in
fact I would never go to a Jew and
saying whoever you think as a wife
killer
I don't eat the gusting you in there
chuckling that was what was it was a
terrible villain or do you believe it
was under it was under the all
convenient or DePalma point yeah that's
why it's very very good point now I'm
going to I'm going to get you are you
telling me I telling me guys well as
well as well as well listen carefully
Misha very important point when I came a
statue which one is worse I mean seeing
that I'm white I'm better than you as a
black person for my lineage you get a
lead and me they are the same step going
to a Jew and say in our business
everybody say okay so you can you look
like a wide attention there no I'm not
going into that yeah because I said I'm
asking your process evolved licensees
are great or said that race yeah it's a
separate entity in itself because what
you have turning around you here at
image is a moment
gimme the name is Ali Baba yeah
Swimming's Alexander restate your watch
your video and you getting married I
understand it is a fact totally changed
my thing right
I'm just saying hopefully change my
village I don't before that you were a
good brother give some credit for
anything from traffic video Thank You
bacon on that but I'm just lost my
pointer yes also you thing about that
hit or not I think you'll about this one
is worth the legislature but as far as
I'm concerned you've got black people
stranded around here who are the
descendants of black people who went
through a real Holocaust when I said to
you is your name al-adawiya even
delivered our digital we get the same
our zawa yeah we was fantastic for you
and for your culture and I'll explain to
you what I mean I can absolutely
guarantee with the 40 or 50 people
surrounding us fear that if I go to a
black person and I said well what's your
surname
you know what he would say to me
then Smith Robinson daily love our dog
this is what they looking at it this is
a sure sign yeah that we are descended
yeah of such the world's greatest
Holocaust yes the world the greatest
follicle yet today very few of us speak
our own language in the way in which you
do have very few bark on our own God the
way in which our usual speaking
generally I want to pay you much you a
man we can generate very few BOTS have
our own culture we have a bastardized
culture which has been given to us by
the old sort of inflator yes so if we
don't carry our own names yeah if we
don't carry our own language we don't
have our own culture they give us a path
to that culture
yeah until we are hosted if we believe
that we believe that coal chanel is rice
and peas on a Sunday we understand or
dollar price for the weekend album put
the reason one point - in our nail i'ma
tell you the reason why because race as
I said cheers is very specific when it's
raised it's not just the race it's what
we've experienced as a particular racial
category as a particular category in a
in a in a in a racist world yeah and I'm
saying that you have the benefit of not
going through what we have gone through
so when you ask me to equate lineage
with rank I refuse okay so and you have
every right to yes and it's a very
crucial point what you said I am 100%
with you because you're saying to me I
need to bring that and that to the level
it's not the same and I'm hundreds in
with you so I need to ask a simple
question when the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him said in such harsh words for
a man who's just talking about lineage
let's go with your argument it's like a
Pokemon rated M symmetry well what do
you think the [ __ ] would have paid it
became a racially I put here across
infer if once is I'm going to go with
what you said that's an image and racism
else no similar but not the same thing
if I even if I go with that I have the
big question it's a profit for so harsh
words and told the matter go by in
father's penis over a matter of image
what do you think we would say about a
man who came of age
much worse though maybe much worse than
so that shows to me and it's an evidence
to me by the way that the Fourth
Amendment if he was so harsh on a much
of lineage and another thing that he
said if I'm not mistaken in a narration
of a man who came with nationalism and
we said decision is under my feet or
something along those lines so the
puppet is always trying to put it into
their brain now and even that the
companion was racist - black companion
yes what did he what it is column Sigma
because you are still in the time of
ignorance and that man had to go and put
his head on the floor and ask the black
companion set over it or go over it as a
humiliation this clearly shows in the
matter of aspects of Islam racism so
forget about it is Muslim the racist
okay there is yet a subsidy no man comes
my time I want to just one point the
matter of Zara when I said look you're
more respectful
now I sometimes be inferiority complex
and some that brothers why because the
fact that I mentioned that not so much
when you came and said hey look there's
a shop going on here they try to comment
divide and conquer
I think that was not fair because in no
way shape or form was I trying to
insinuate that but the fact that you say
that and when I hear other people say
that it shows to me there's an impurity
context that's clouding your judgment we
should aspect how how Europe gave me out
here in the outer rim because I never
came assets you say no a bespoke to Gary
and sorrow against those animus said
that when I said was sorry disrespectful
and it should not only what is Bravo
just the way I would see another was
anything you know a man whose look at
that brother so learn something it's not
a way of could you give examples of a I
see them do in a community Hey look I'm
sorry I totally reject that in no way
was that insinuating divide and conquer
that's rubbish because why Black Muslim
brothers around me it's ridiculous for
me to go inside oh hey Vic we divide and
conquer so that's why I reject our
statement of and your way of thinking it
makes you seem a little inferior too
complex which I might be wrong and I'm
wrong on apologize but I've seen like
that now now that was it
okay yes first episode is animated thank
you I don't think that it is an
inferiority complex by myself because
what I'm speaking about are actual
statements of fact the videos that I
mentioned whereby I you know the touchid
and the point and then you're so very
much different than him you understand
these are particular tactics that have
been used against black people in the
West for the last 500 years so this is
not paranoia or an inferiority complex
on my side and the truth is that you
spoke to most black people most like
people privately they would tell you the
same in fact there are many conversation
that black men had would reach other
that you're not aware of when you speak
about an inferiority complex it's not
something that I understand when I think
that you might be on the right side if
you say that perhaps I'm a little bit
unbalanced and I may well accept that
argument but then there is a reason for
that as well imagine something that I've
said in the part of a couple weeks ago
and there was a group of black guys who
were around me and I was explaining that
I just came back from Southeast Asia and
before someone went on the map I said
when a black guy comes back from
somewhere which is what we say
untraditional like like Nigeria or
Jamaica or Barbado or whatever and you
speak about a country that you've just
come from which is not traditional for
you in South Asia
if you speak to a black guy do you know
when you telling you being there you
know the first question he asked you you
know if I went to Southeast Asia
I'm just a little bit good to do like an
experiment if I want to Southeast Asia
and I just come back what would be one
of the first questions you ask me how
are you
thank you very much did you hear that
lifeline oh you get at me you're shocked
at that like when I didn't point seemed
I don't know this man because this is
what that this is what this is what
black people say because they understood
they understand it they understand yeah
at a level above a scientific a
religious a possible level it's called
racism word so I don't know this man and
yet when I did this a couple of weeks
ago
immediately they search how will you
treat it uncle fees when you go to an
African control no no I what we go to a
non-traditional Andre oh now I'm just
showing hand I'm just showing you how
delicious and for permission free from
it and I said to you that when you
pointed out some things that I said and
if you said that I was unbalanced I
would have said that yes I'm unbalanced
in some of my views but I try to myself
and say I rather was unbalanced your
paintings okay no but the reason why I
say am imbalance is because of the
experiences that we've had is likely
dense and so I'm arching you then if we
go to long traditional country and you
stay two black people no matter what
strategy out how much money they have
yeah but what intellectual level they
are yet the first thing you say to them
if you go to Australia yeah if you go to
Japan if you go to Thailand you go to
Ken bode you come back and you're
explaining to a black guy so I wouldn't
the portrait they say well how they
treat you over there because you know
what they're trying to you know what
they're trying to assess in their own
mind based on what he said I wonder if I
should go over there you know many of us
may have money in related as Nigeria but
we underrated only and only many of us
many of us are confined to where we know
because of that fear of racism there is
a real genuine fear with it my most
likely but I know and the black I mean I
know that you don't want to go anywhere
whereby you're going to have thrown on
you
additional racism to where you come from
and so when you don't give all of us the
million and one questions yeah but if
you go to Cambodia and you go out at
night how do they look at you you go
into a Kappa and you might say like god
these people are paranoid it's not
paranoia right yeah it's not absolutely
ecstatic cold we can't I should point
out something just I think one of the
one of the things that yes be careful as
well I think that usually wouldn't
answer present we don't ask them some
everyone or are the braces that's
exactly the point I was trying to make
you so I don't know why should I repeat
yeah my healthier other people follow
those because I apologize so other
people not immediately don't realize I
don't realize now I understand and tell
it on the computer and so and so you can
then understand the context that won't I
can say that some of what much
said some of what's RR say you know is
it a little bit spicy
yesterday's the no human second but when
I explained to you the contact where to
say that we are balanced other people I
believe that a lot of us are yeah but
it's in that context when you hear this
man say what he said it's that context
where I say that Farah is my brother and
I love him and all back in because you
see the thing is with far too quick to
point our finger and turn our back on
each other because one thing has been
said that we dislike then I'm saying
that he remains my brother regardless
because I know what his parents have
gone through I know what my parents of
some of my my old man was alive some of
the stuff that he said I am I am
surprised but me and my problems haven't
turned out to be serial killers Jennifer
with summary and you should relate above
are you can't be you are bringing in a
bomb debugging in a very real racism
example of establishing a new realities
of the new religion in the Middle East
when they were already religions that
within or you hope to change that not
equate that with a different icon equate
are they broken said something that I
also have to object you answer when you
say that what you may said was
unbalanced forces yeah I don't think
that because here we're talking about
context yes if is actually within the
context of your life your life
experience and they the reason is
fundamentally a valid reason for you to
pay that way here in certain balance
there's perfect balance it's just not
opening on yeah you're right you're
right so go Dunbar aren't open or know
what if you're right because I liked it
never get me you know it so the thing is
okay we need to have concept that's what
hits you you should relate with Abubakar
why you shouldn't say all you know what
he's one was good for religion mine was
raised to know and oppress
oppression there's no he's with a smile
without we all should relate like you
said somebody what they've gone through
if I have been belittled by black people
for example and be seen and be sad yes
I'm going to be bitter but I think a
personality yes there might be more
balance being imbalance but I'd have to
balance out how I would have to say you
know what yet black people have treated
me bad but for me to go out and every
time someone tests on you're a black
person I look and get an R I have a
right to fire it's just about discipline
in oneself in you know what maybe they
know like that but that's a different
topic can we agree big bro that what
Ibaka's change and what your forefathers
went through like you said you did I
wouldn't be in a serial killer yes
Abubakar forget me in a serial killer he
just said a few words yet so I just want
to establish and make it very clear we
have no problem with you criticizing our
religion that's why we are out here and
different places in the UK asking you
guys to come and become our religion so
we can clarify for you insults when it
comes to insult
insult is bad I disagree I disagree yet
this doesn't mean I said it again I said
it before I'm not seeing I agree with
the person who will go and attack him or
once inside physical say him yet I
disagree with the action would I
understand it yes I would
would I agree with it no I won't what I
do the same no I'm not gonna drop series
level you want stuff from me you want to
action I'm not in it is up to the devil
and Sarah did this before a night climb
evils away I just want to make you clear
Islam has no racism let's differentiate
between criticism and insult if somebody
insults and you can say my mug is
insulting your honor in criticizing
religion no that's not criticizing
criticizing is come in and say look I
want to know why Allah said this Allah
says for example go and kill them
wherever you find it go and kill them
wherever you find them you're going to
come and say I want to know this sounds
with perfect criticizing let me to my
fellow mistake you know you're both
better I'm going to say Bob I'm going to
talk to you when you coming to me with
that behavior so I think we're always
talking same thing we're talking the
same day oh yeah we're going to do some
closing points for my mark on my side
for myself closing points I think even
people are talking about same thing
we're talking about the same thing 9
percent of the time we agree we both
disagree that someone should run and so
we both agree oakley criticizes
Christina village and realized our job
is to come and answer them
aggression were both against aggression
yes on night night I would say look I
understand the one whose mother's been
insulted or his profiles are being
called the monkey or decide whatever I
understand that guy being frustrated and
wanting to do something
do I agree with it no but we understand
the situation yes I do of course I do
coming to Islam can we agree that is
some does not teach racism but is some
in no way shape teaches individuals to
go and and it's not closes thing by the
way that teaches us to go and be
insulting and disrespectful and use foul
language I want to finish off with a few
narration the others not closing
observing the Prophet Mohammed keeps the
economy's our role model and he said I
did not come from nothing but a suspect
the good character there is and you also
said there is absolutely nothing that is
heavier on the scale of belief than one
good manners this is from Abu Dhabi
there is absolutely nothing that I do on
the scale that will behaviors in good
manners and the person with good manners
will attain the rank of the person of
fasting and prayer young guys anyway
fasting and pre-op this is one of the
two pillars of Islam the Prophet
Mohammed particular said a man with good
manners good conduct with people is
better than that one to be fast and pray
there is many many other narrations the
Prophet Muhammad peace people never
taught the behavior that certain Muslim
Julia and non-muslims by the way caused
a few weeks ago there was a Christian
its
few Christian guys attacking this guy
Jimmy scribe and people of rcv Muslims I
was like wow so understand save this
it's not the suspicious
this is that remember just let me just
finish my I'll make my closing argument
firstly Kwame Dakota nominals I'd like
to thank our legal war and I'd have to
say to you that I had a very negative
opinion of of a leader lon and I watched
the YouTube video when you know he was
getting married and some of the stuff
that he went through and I couldn't
believe it I've actually quite touched
by something and he became human in
front of my eyes reason why I pointed
out is that we're very quick sometimes
to point our fingers at other and not
ascribe humanity to them I think that
I'm also guilty of that from time to
time and it's a hole in my character
that I'm looking to improve there are
four points that I want to make the
first one that I want to make is there
initially when we spoke earlier on today
we were speaking about
Basara incidentally I think it's very
clear that there are a small group of
Muslims and a small group of super
ignorant Muslims a new strain that a
valid Iowa says who don't read who have
a very basic understanding of Islam who
are quick to anger who are doing a great
disservice the Muslim Ummah and I think
that they should be rejected they should
be rejected and they should be
challenged at every single step with
what they do
Sarang I will make clear again have the
right to his opinion even though a lot
of what his opinion is is not my opinion
but it remains my brother I think that's
important second point is it very very
important sometimes when Ali is reading
certain scriptural words from the
prophet of Allah Islam
can I can I dispute that so I can't
dispute that the understand will want to
the student no I don't want to dispute
it however there are many other verses
which have not been pulled up today
regarding what I say are the actions of
the prophet of Allah Islam and I say
that they should be allowed to be
critiqued they should be allowed to be
critiqued openly a strong religion has
people who have very very strong
argument and they will be able to deal
with people who who who wish to critique
it because they genuinely believe that
what they have heard makes no sense at
all I think one of the things that has
concerned me with my part with the
Muslims I don't know many people like me
but when I come down here I like to hear
good strong arguments long here whether
it comes from Christians Muslims whoever
I don't believe what they believe but
like I believe in the strength of a
cogent argument and unfortunately there
are very few Muslims there was one
particular Muslim a dog with a thick his
name were watched from afar for Jesus
he's brilliant
the understand honestly told everybody
content video and all that it was
brilliant and then I saw his action and
I'm not a little bit of respect for it
in the army they don't know what a
little bit of a little bit of respect
for it and I thought well he's that way
because he's young
hopefully he'll bounce back before he
was going to be the great hope for young
Muslims
and for Hyde Park muscle resection and I
thought this is this is Preston Hall the
third point I'm going to make is this is
that you mentioned race and that's one
that's one thing that does that does
sometimes trigger black people or
dark-skinned people and you mentioned
that there was no racism in Islam it's
interesting that Muslims continually say
that it would be somehow if they
continually repeat it it must be true
however on a another day there's an old
party trip that I have who are mentioned
27 different hobbies yeah of action that
I that I say are racist and how black
people are described in North IDs
unfortunately when I speak about them
they challenge the Hadees they say it's
the if the old if the old I don't like
to play beta to a fed-up earlier and I
should apologize for that because that's
not what I meant
sometimes then sometimes for worse the
whale opposed a silver but they were
there there are many Hadees for me which
are deeply racist and the way in which
black people are describe a particular
race a particularly racism actually
mentioned one one hadith and in that
particular hadith and as gamma hobbies I
don't remember
the direct quotes but there was one
where my it was stated if anybody says
that Muhammad alayhi Salam as a black
man they should be killed they
understand they should be killed people
again I dine with and graduated from a
gestated and I was I was waiting for
that to come out as well we all realized
that the hadith didn't really start to
be compound until about 200 years after
the death of Muhammad Lakeland and we
know that world from from my own study
it has been about 600,000 are these have
been rejected that have been rejected by
in the area well but I'm Justin about
what are some that have been rejected by
those who say that they are Muslim
scholars so of course you would reject
which that which doesn't fully fully
comply with your narrative and a clear
what annual are to
point exists few times Muslims make
statements and I believe that when they
make these statements I believe that
they are they are honest and they are
sincere and sometimes I can come over as
quite rude when I say I don't care what
you say as a Muslim because you can say
whatever you like I want to speak just
to just to the Quran and the Sunnah and
the Quran backs me up early the Quran
really does back me up so our leaders
finished River River the Earth from the
ground I'd like to do so also and it's
there - back up - back up - back up my
point in untreated no not to be yeah I
need the power denied laughs I learned
on mines in my bag bellarmin I know that
law doesn't have much time something it
from a harness
one of the reasons why I believe that
Muslims say a lot of the things they say
and I believe some of them are sincere
it doesn't mean that because they
believe this and hear that I should
accept it because the last word the last
word if you are Muslim is the Koran you
understand so and it's this it is not
for a believing man or a believing woman
when Allah and His Messenger has decided
a matter that they should have any
choice about their affair and will be
disobeys Allah and His Messenger are
certainly straight into clear error let
me point out what that means you as a
Muslim you know any of you that you want
you can say anything to anybody that you
want but if it goes against if it goes
against the very clear construction here
of the Quran and of muhammad aleyhi
salam which he says come from Allah what
Allah innocence then I don't have to
listen to you so in the absence of that
do you know what I do because this is
one of the verses that I've held fast to
a twenty-seven years what I do is this
many Muslims will say that you have to
separate yes miss length from Islam let
me tell you this those who say they
follow the Sunnah of Rasulullah
with them I watch you very closely
because you are the representatives of
that and so when you go around what mean
to harm people
let mean to disrespect people
threatening to beat people up
frightening to pay attention because you
don't like what they say you know what I
do I don't listen to what you say I
listen to what the quran says and the
quran is very clear the quran is very
clear if that's what you believe in you
follow muhammad alayhi salam and you
follow his sunnah
it's what about what you believe as
muslim it's about the clear instruction
that allah gives you and once I see many
Muslims many Muslims I don't see too
many practitioners of Islam but I just
like to thank Darwin I think I was very
good brother
I want to thank people it goes with it I
think this was an amazing conversation
and I want to have this conversation
you're not fed up of shouting or
consultants etc however before if you're
finishing I want to touch upon a few
things I said I want I would love you
know if you have 27 degrees your current
I would love to have a discussion about
that girl and if you can bring them and
you know one thing that remember today
73 there which is number one thing we
said that is that if it's choose the
agenda of the Muslims they accepted it
or they don't
we have a principle we have the size of
a deal and the way the side of a leaf
works is not simple as look I shall the
passo sella marina at 9:00 it's a nice
I'm not going to come and say to you nah
it was 19 this night and we have our
valid argument well why this happens and
when it's actually said well before you
like a 50 before we can get into that
people say well why because this is a
large topic on its own the answer it is
enough money so we can discuss that
because the judge the judge something
1400 years ago with me is the big thing
which is a big fallacy you know why a
woman today you can walk around on a
bikini on today take them over 1,400
years is almost an aperture do you see
my point
but then the norms of their time in
other rooms of today and the north of
today is not the number of that day so
for someone to come and say well it's I
need expense you need X that's another
topic which was about that however why
was for poison about
the hadith we have these are authentic
that are sounded what the way the hadith
are compiled and the scrutiny they go
through big Road if you can not see
typical you said you were moving before
yes okay working I want to say to if we
could sit down with you and aren't I
don't know why you let the Sun if we go
through that and we answer your question
in your head are you like a plane my
mind normally samo are you like you know
what I've criticized given I'm a company
which is from an argument if you're
open-minded I am more than any day
anytime come to our by the way you know
blood rinse yeah okay this is this this
here continue everything I was injured
if this is a chain of transmission yeah
we know in today's time I have teachers
that teachers go back to the Prophet we
have a dream this plan is not like
Christianity I don't mean this in a way
like we are better we have changed we
know each individual how we utter did
what he said when we see two examples
will be a liar with the a fabricator
this is protein generation so the 27°
are you bring to this I would have to
look at their change week fabricated
value Center could what's authentic what
does it say in the words I use so if you
can our longtime discussion about those
27 hadith that you claim is racism here
and if we go over it and we're spirit
here clear racism there's no doubt I I
believe totally no way still and so I
think the next discussion should be
about those 27:33 joking again Lee yes
I'm going to be my research on yeah now
we're going to be special oh really yeah
that's true hopefully nation equals big
role and again I want to thank you for
his kind words being polite and weird
lovely discussion how people learn a
benefit and like I said before Muslims
you guys are representative of Islam
your behavior your conduct is very
important I'm sorry you guys need to do
I'm sorry
after you real go back to Islam and
implement it's lamp not your ego and I'm
not seeing everybody excited because
we're talking about violence is law
violence is done by difficult of
different races different religions so
I'm talking about the Muslims in High
Park and then reminded to me manners
manners manners thank you very much
Joseph oh hey give me one I'm sorry
subscribe